faire ses achats grâce à un ordinateur
et avec une carte de crédit cela
s'appelle le commerce électronique très
développé aux états unis il a du mal à
démarrer en france c'est peut-être tout
simplement un problème de barrières
psychologiques
reportage de dominique vatel et
dominique duchateau infaillible mais
peut-être un peu lourd ce système qui
n'autorise le paiement électronique qu'à
la sixième signature identique toute
approximation étant rejeté plus
classique voici le paiement par carte
bleue après autorisation et codification
préalable mais au bout du compte
d'opérations et fait encore bon nombre
d'internautes français
obsédé par la sécurisation des paiements
sur ce réseau ouvert à tous les vents
internet a mauvaise réputation de ce
côté là on prétend que tout ce qui
transite transit en clair et la
structure même du réseau fait que
n'importe qui peut examiner
l'information début janvier 98 on va
arriver à avoir des solutions qui seront
vraiment efficace et qui fonctionneront
en réel sur le réseau l'avenir c'est
donc le cryptage à grande échelle qui
interdit à l'utilisateur de lire les
informations d'une autre personne car
sans sécurité
pas de décollage réel du commerce
électronique sur internet
voilà en tout cas ce que ses ingénieurs
ont bien compris et puisque l'acheteur
français hésitent encore à confier au
logiciel code confidentiel et
informations personnelles
on installe chez lui un lecteur de carte
bancaire exactement comme chez le
commerçant
il est rassuré par le fait de toucher sa
carte bancaire et donc de saisir son
numéro de carte au niveau local
uniquement avant ciel non il était
obligé de donner son numéro de carte sur
le réseau internet
aujourd'hui il n'a plus à le faire
cryptage ou terminale pour car il faut
qu'une solution fiable s'impose 10 des
commerciaux d'autant qu'il ya encore du
pain sur la planche
le commerce sur le seul minitel et tente
aujourd'hui encore le double du commerce
mondial sur internet et